[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonne soirée
bonsoir marraine bonne soirée
comment ça va ça va très bien et tu m'as
beaucoup manqué
vous avez des nouvelles de César
il paraît qu'il est un chien en ce
moment
oui j'ai vu le film
et vous
toi numéro 10 j'ai appris que tu as
marié
une gauloise
de Grenoble magnifique
au début c'était pas évident avec ma
famille égyptienne et maintenant il
s'adore
ce n'est ce n'est oh merci pour tout tes
compliments
mais maintenant on laisse la place la
nouvelle génération et à tous ces jeunes
merveilleux qui avec leur énergie et
l'air talent font la force de la Gaule
pardon
de la France c'est un synonyme marraine
vous pouvez c'est pas vous excusez